welcome to Hannity we start tonight with
a Fox News Alert it was a huge day at
the White House presidents from signing
phase one of what is a historic new
trade deal with China that will benefit
so many sectors of our economy jobs GDP
straight on down the line now for years
and years and decades China has been
taking full advantage of this country
far too long and no president has been
up to the challenge of getting freer and
fairer trade deals with China and others
the great news is this agreement will
now bring hundreds of billions of
dollars in revenue to American farmers
American manufacturers are energy and
service industries and much more over
two hundred billion dollars and that's
just the next two years alone and this
is yet another major promise made
promise cap by the president that you
will never hear from in the media mob we
have all those details very big day
today for American workers will tell you
all about it first while the president
was busy making deals to improve the
lives of we the American people
congressional Democrats oh just doing
what they've done for three years
wasting your time your tax dollars with
a political stunt
the latest one today after inexplicably
stalling for weeks we have a very
deranged Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi Pelosi speaker name only finally
announcing her hand-selected impeachment
managers and officially transmitting
would think that she thinks she's
president she did this so prayerfully
these articles to the Senate it's a very
important day for us and as you know one
reference temporal markers that our
founders and our poets and others have
used over time to place us in time to
emphasize the importance of time because
everything is about time how we use it
how we make how we mark it and today is
an important day because today is the
day that we name the managers who go to
the floor to pass the resolution
to transmit the articles of impeachment
to the Senate then the signing was even
worse because after that bizarre presser
Pelosi transmitted the articles to the
Senate but not before a very gleeful
prayerful ceremony where Pelosi signed
off on the process she used an
assortment of pans she's distributed at
all to her smiling colleagues here take
this you're gonna want this give this to
your children well that was so prayerful
such urgency it pass it before Christmas
urgently and they go on vacation and
they hold it even longer this is all
part of her solemn duty remember and as
for the impeachment manager she shall up
selected frankly a gift to Donald Trump
they represent the Democrats last chance
to persuade the Senate Republicans on
the merits of their case but this is the
whole process has been a shift sham show
and a political hit job from beginning
to end
well Pelosi unless she wants to keep
that job on speaker selected a group of
the most hyper partisan conspiracy
theorists Trump haters in the Democratic
caucus and back she hired every single
most radical extreme delusional Trump
aiding Democrat six out of the seven
managers supported impeachment long
before the fake non whistleblower
hearsay whistleblower filed a complaint
as the Federals pointed out all the
managers are steeled dossier truthers
and let's get to know these you know
tinfoil hats from painting conspiracy
theorists leading the way this is a gift
for the president none other than he
compromised in this case corrupt
congenital liar Adam Schiff the guy that
needs to be called as a witness in this
case and like his fellow managers yes
the congenital liar has spent years
spreading the Russia collusion hoax
he lied for three straight years
non-stop he said there was significant
ample evidence of Trump Russia collusion
he fully endorsed a phony steel dossier
totally untrue lying daily through his
teeth and more recently fabricating the
transcript of the president's call with
the Ukrainian president entering it it
into the official record of Congress and
that's not all yeah
the congenital Liars office oh we now
know was in contact with the fake
hearsay whistleblower before he or she
filed a complaint I said what we'd love
to hear from him another lie tried to
cover up that contact keeping it a
secret even lying about it on national
TV but after he was caught in that
bold-faced lie he refused to allow them
to unwish a blower to testify which he
originally said what happened shift is a
fact witness in his own shift show and
that was also de facto prosecutor
that's right Pelosi A's lead manager as
a guy that should be called as a witness
in the case and you say conflict of
interest oh and one of the most disliked
people in Congress and interestingly we
played it many times he is the only guy
on tape that we hear in his own words
conspiring with somebody he believes to
be a Russian to get dirt on Donald Trump
and the dirt on Donald Trump so he can
use it in a campaign oh I thought that
was there what is the nature of it
compromising my idea we've compromising
materials and what's the nature of the
compromised naked pictures of Romney and
naked pics it does Vladimir know that's
all on tape with him yesterday
last-ditch effort Hail Mary smear job
yep the congenital liar attached new
documents to the articles of impeachment
including so-called evidence from of a
former Giuliani contact oh by the way on
conspiracy TV the guy is facing federal
charges from the Southern District of
New York they don't really want to mess
with those people campaign finance
violations whole bunch of other stuff so
it goes right to state-run MSDN see
conspiracy channel media and keep in
mind when people like him trying to stay
out of jail now think about this how
many times have we heard from the
Liberals no you can't waterboard or use
enhanced interrogation because people
will say anything they'll lie to make it
end well people trying to stay out of
jail of my humble opinion they'll say
anything but if you're willing to smear
Trump you're always welcome and by the
way even people indicted that want a
lesson potential jail sentences they're
welcome on NBC Tom Brokaw you must be so
proud but back to the topic at hand
another manager
by Pelosi another first-rate hypocrite
from New York Jerrold Nadler November
2016 only days after the election
neither issued a dramatic Proclamation
writing quote we can't wait for years to
vote mr. Trump out of office he wanted
to impeach Trump the day he was elected
also promising that if he was appointed
Judiciary Committee Chairman he would
impeach Trump what for we'll make it up
as we go there's despite railing against
the impeachment of Bill Clinton in 98
didn't even want the Starr report which
was mandated by law with eleven felonies
Ken Starr identified crimes really
committed by Bill Clinton he didn't even
want that public but he wanted of course
the robert muller report not mandated by
law to go out the special counsel law
which replaced the Independent Counsel
law other lesser-known managers
appointed by Pelosi just as unhinge they
got congresswoman Val Demi's
congresswoman congressman Jason Crowe
supporting impeachment after the Moller
report the fourth investigation found
zero evidence of Trump Russia collusion
or conspiracy fellow managers Sylvia
Garcia supported congressman al Green's
baseless impeachment resolution over
nothing from July 17th meanwhile another
manager congresswoman and armchair
psychologist Zoe Lofgren once said
President was an old person suffering
from mental decline oh I guess she
wasn't talking about Joe Biden who
openly invites by the way foreign
interference and last but not least is
Hakeem Jeffries that every racist in
America voted for Donald Trump Wow
presidents the KKK Grand Wizard 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue these are the
deranged idiots representing impeachment
before the Senate how fitting with these
appointments you have to wonder is
Pelosi that desperate catering to the
extreme it's same base of a party to
cling to her speakership she's not
really speaker anymore I'd be the squad
that would be a Cassio Cortes she speak
her name only and after claiming urgency
got to get this done then go on vacation
so urgent we got to go on vacation and
then stalling for weeks after that
constitutional scholar Jonathan Turley
he wrote Pelosi quote destroy
her own case for impeachment even fake
news CNN every once in a while they get
something right they're claiming Pelosi
gamble and she lost now the Senate trial
will start sometime next week Pelosi is
impeachment yes those people now have
their opportunity to present their week
their partisan unfounded articles of
impeachment and be helping the president
because the American people see through
this this shift sham show now the Senate
thanks to some weak Republican senators
unfortunately there's hell-bent on
helping this corrupt process when they
should be putting an end to it
they want to waste time and call
witnesses but I do have good news to
report and that is people like senator
Ted Cruz of Texas reportedly floating a
pretty interesting idea and a deal
witness reciprocity that means Democrats
can call witnesses take for example Mick
Mulvaney John Bolton Mike Pompeo
whatever all who likely won't testify
because it's the president that has the
right to use executive privilege like
every other president before him and he
said he'd use it just like Obama just
like Clinton just like everyone else but
then Republicans could call whoever they
want that means I say call quid pro quo
Joe I say call zero experience hunter or
at the very center of what is a real
Ukrainian scandal you're not getting the
billion taxpayer dollars unless you fire
the prosecutor that is investigating
zero experience son of mine who's being
paid millions and millions of dollars
game if you had fire of they'll give you
the billion that was the great thing
about the new evidence that presented
yesterday Joe Biden and hunter are
totally innocent the prosecutor was for
up always the prosecutor corrupt he saw
a company paying money that no other
company would pay for zero experience
looking into it
the compromise congenital liar let's
bring him in the non whistleblower
hearsay whistleblower let's bring in the
non here say they here say whistleblower
people seem to forget the president well
he's faithfully execute the laws of the
land that would mean he has a duty that
would mean that he has an obligation
he made a pledge to investigate
potential crimes which old Biden is
emitting too is a crime in my book he's
right
from quit and a pro and a quo with Joe
and the millions of dollars zero
experience hunter received from that
Ukrainian giant and of course as a
father was overseeing all the policy in
Ukraine now what business this is not a
tough this is not a tough Jeopardy
question what business would ever pay
millions of millions of dollars to
somebody who has zero experience I can't
think of one except a company that might
be trying to buy influence bring in quid
pro quo Joe and zero experience hunter
let's get all the facts on the table
it's time to see the full picture it's
time to have equal justice under the law
equal application of our laws not just
the skewed view from Adam shifts beady
little eyes